[Musica]
[Applauso]
Ci troviamo nella Laguna di sarò libero
in Paraguay
Guardate la laguna è divisa in due da
una strada
da un lato della strada vedete che il
colore dell'acqua è un colore normale a
cui siamo abituati e la vegetazione è
cresce dall'altro lato della strada
L'acqua ha un colore viola
i pesci muoiono
cosa sta succedendo
lì accanto sorge una conceria
che ha riversato in quelle acque delle
sostanze nocive come cromo e cianuro
sento per la prima volta parlare di Fas
o pifas
sono sostanze chimiche velenose che
vengono utilizzate anche nell'industria
conciaria per rendere idropellenti le
pelli
pensate che sono 17 mila le aree
contaminate da Fassi in tutta Europa
e questo è un disastro ambientale
gigantesco degli ultimi 50 anni ma non è
soltanto un disastro ambientale Questo è
un disastro anche per le persone perché
attraverso l'acqua che beviamo il cibo
che mangiamo i Fast sono entrati nel
nostro sangue
ora voi Forse state pensando
che sono problemi lontani da noi siamo
in Italia sono problemi lontanissimi
in realtà
nel Veneto
e dal 2013 da quando sono stati scoperti
che si parla di inquinamento da Fas
nelle acque
e questo ha colpito
tantissimo gli abitanti del Veneto
causando ovviamente delle gravissime
malattie ma non riguarda soltanto gli
abitanti del Veneto perché
il cibo irrigato con quell'acqua lo
mangiamo tutti
Quindi cosa possiamo fare noi per
cambiare
o per aiutare a risolvere questa
situazione
è stato guardando
alla nostra terra
e alla Sicilia da dove vengo
È stato lì che abbiamo visto una
possibile soluzione cioè tonnellate
tonnellate di sottoprodotto che ogni
anno viene generato dall'industria di
trasformazione degli agrumi e delle pale
di fico d'India frutti di cui siamo
veramente conosciuti in tutto il mondo
che potevamo valorizzare e trasformare
in un'alternativa alla pelle animale
quindi
immaginatevi
un'arancia e una pala di fico d'India
insieme sono diventati questo
ma sono diventati anche questo
e sono diventati tantissimi dei prodotti
che noi ogni giorno Indossiamo
Oggi ti sostenibilità Santiago parlare
ovunque tutti parlano di sostenibilità
si sente tantissimo la parola
sostenibilità e i messaggi che ci
vengono dati Se ci pensate sembrano
quasi tutti uguali no
il prodotti per essere sostenibili
devono essere biodegradabili
i prodotti per essere sostenibili non
devono contenere plastica
dobbiamo rinunciare a qualcosa per
salvare il nostro pianeta sono
tantissime parole moltissime ma pochi
fatti perché un'altra parola di
sostenibilità è diventata ormai
famosissima e greenwashing
cioè una strategia di comunicazione
adottata dalle aziende che presentano e
illudono i consumatori di pratiche
sostenibili nelle loro attività e tutto
questo
utilizzando parole come Green bio senza
fornire però fonti dati quindi solo fumo
del marketing
E pensate che l'Unione Europea
pochissimi mesi fa a gennaio di
quest'anno ha fatto una analisi di tutti
i messaggi di sostenibilità delle
aziende delle nostre aziende e ha
scoperto che il 53% del messaggio di
sostenibilità delle aziende sono vaghi
il 40% non offre prove a sostegno di ciò
che dice
quindi la sostenibilità sono fatti e
dati
due parole
degradabilità o durabilità
sono entrambi alleati della
sostenibilità
vi porto un esempio
tutti andiamo a fare la spesa
tutti andiamo al supermercato Giusto
allora poi fate la vostra spesa prendete
le vostre cose arrivate alla cassa
arrivata alla cassa e vi danno la busta
biodegradabile Ok mettiamo tutto dentro
la busta via della rabbia Ops sono il
sacchetto capita che si rompe quindi Beh
Ok l'avvio della vita ma i prodotti
devono durare nel tempo Chi vuole una
borsa
un paio di scarpe un divano o pensate il
sedile della vostra automobile o lo
sterzo che dopo poco tempo si spera si
rovina Si spacca Eh i prodotti devono
durare devono essere utilizzabili per
tutto il ciclo di vita
questa è dura la durabilità è
sostenibilità
e quando si parla di durabilità non
possiamo non nominare la plastica
e l'invenzione
più nota che ha reso
una delle più grandi forse invenzioni
che ha reso i nostri prodotti durevoli
e quindi la plastica
tutti i messaggi di sostenibilità dicono
non usate la plastica la plastica è un
nemico o è un alleato della
sostenibilità
Noi siamo sommersi dalla plastica se ne
producono 460 milioni di tonnellate nel
mondo di tutta questa plastica che cosa
dobbiamo fare Ci sta soffocando solo il
10% viene riciclato Ecco noi abbiamo
inserito plastica riciclata nella nostra
composizione con arancio e Pale di fico
d'India e questo non solo ha fatto sì
che il nostro prodotto sia durevole nel
tempo
ma ha dimostrato che Inserendo la
plastica riciclata e quindi facendo
diventare la plastica nostra alleata per
la sostenibilità il nostro impatto nel
mondo diminuisce perché con il calcolo
della RCA dati Noi abbiamo dimostrato
che per un metro quadro di no del nostro
materiale e mettiamo due punto 57 kg di
CO2 contro i 3 92 kg di co 2 messi dalle
altre alternative fatte con puliretano e
contro i 110 kg di CO2 emessi nel mondo
dalla pelle conciata al cromo
le sostanze chimiche dannose
Oggi sono qui a Modena dalla Sicilia a
Modena a parlarvi di sostenibilità nella
città dei motori nel piano del motor
Valley Fest
l'industria della pelle Entro il 2025
varrà 600 miliardi di dollari il 40 per
cento di queste Industrie all'assorbirà
il settore Automotive con 242 miliardi
di dollari sono cifra gigantesche
e aumenterà la domanda di sedili in
pelle per il loro aspetto lussuoso
e il lusso
cos'è il lusso può essere Quindi anche
un materiale che è fatto con
sottoprodotti di arancia e pare di fico
d'India che comunque abbatte l'impatto
che ha la plastica nel mondo e quindi
aiuta a risolvere un problema che sta
soffocando il nostro pianeta e quindi il
nuovo lusso può essere sostenibile Sì
per noi sì un nuovo lusso deve essere
sostenibile un nuovo lusso deve
rispettare l'ambiente deve essere giusto
per le persone deve essere giusto per
gli animali e tutti noi non dobbiamo per
forza rinunciare a qualcosa che ci piace
e che bello Anzi possiamo aiutare con
gli oggetti che ci piacciono affinché
questo non esista mai più nel mondo ma
esista questo
[Applauso]